[Applause]
do you remember when you used to look
forward to your birthday for a while
getting old it was exciting every year
made you smarter faster bigger and
stronger you could do more in a day and
as bedtimes became more lakhs you could
do more in a night - is it 4:00 p.m.
already what happened
ageing that's what happened don't like
your birthday anymore
happy birthday no such thing
tired of feeling tired all the time and
weaker and smaller and slower cheer up
we can fix that for you
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we stopped aging in the past
200 years the average life expectancy on
Earth has more than doubled but despite
being able to live longer we still
haven't figured out a way to stop aging
the very idea of conquering age sounds
impossible not to mention unnatural but
don't act like you wouldn't want that
sweet sweet victory at 25 you're at your
physical best at 40 your body starts
getting weaker does that sound fair to
you don't you wish we could look and
feel our best forever some scientists
believe that it might one day be
possible but is it really what you want
based on what aging is it seems that
it's only a matter of time before we're
able to slow its effects if not stop it
completely
after all aging is simply a biological
process it's what happens when your body
can no longer keep up with repair
you're weakened and damaged cells you'll
also have free radicals to deal with and
know where you're not referring to
counterculture leftist youth to
aggravate older people free radicals are
unstable atoms that your body naturally
produces and they've been proven to
damage cells the resulting cell damage
can lead to a range of diseases that are
typically linked to old age if we get to
an age we really like and then stop our
body from making free radicals our
cellular and molecular structure
wouldn't age as much and that might just
be our ticket to eternal youth but while
that might sound like good news to you
ask yourself is anti aging good for the
earth and of all the people on it you
can imagine how the world would be a
much happier place if we never aged
generally speaking we would have a
healthier population fewer people would
experience the chronic pain that comes
with old age and we'd see an end to
age-related diseases like Alzheimer's
dementia and Parkinson's families could
expect to pay fewer medical costs
providing the healthcare system with
some much-needed relief more people
might live on to meet their great great
grandchildren and even their great great
great grandchildren an ageless world
would be a utopia you could get so much
more out of life crossing off all the
items on your bucket list without
feeling weak tired or worrying about how
much time you had left
barring other causes of death like
accidents or illnesses you might even be
able to live forever but in what kind of
world we might stop aging but we
wouldn't stop reproducing the world
would quickly become a claustrophobic
place Earth's population would boom and
we'd find ourselves increasingly
strained to find enough space for
everybody
and safe and comfortable housing
wouldn't be the only problem how would
we feed everybody
our quality of life would become
increasingly unaffordable as a world
without aging would mean a world with
fewer of retirees newcomers to the
workforce would struggle to earn a
living and this would be made worse by
job cuts in medicine and funeral
services as well as the cosmetics
industry to give you an idea of how
devastating that would be just consider
that the United States funeral industry
alone adds approximately twenty billion
dollars to the national economy every
year as individuals food shelter and how
to pay for them would be some of our top
concerns but about the planet as a whole
Earth has a threshold for how many lives
it can support so if we stopped aging we
quickly use up our world's resources
making the climate crisis so much worse
that we might soon find ourselves
wishing we could grow old just to speed
ourselves out of this nightmare the
thing to remember is that aging and
death while unpleasant are natural
processes even if we don't like growing
old and phasing out humanity as a
species meets it while we grow old Earth
is constantly rejuvenating itself
through evolution every organism on the
planet must one day leave to make room
for new and healthier organisms this is
how the world has stayed young and fit
for billions of years
so while you may not like growing old be
proud of the fact that growing old and
phasing out is part of the bigger
process to keep the earth young and
healthy so that it can continue to
support generations of humans who will
get to enjoy life as much as you have of
course it would be nice to stay young
for a little longer and there are plenty
of scientists who are researching ways
to make it possible the Sens Research
Foundation for example is working on an
anti-aging project called rejuvenation
biotechnology which would reverse the
effects of aging without halting the
process altogether not good enough still
feel like living forever well we can
show you what in more
tality really looks like but that's a
story for another what if